[Music]
that's the wire transfer going it's fine
now Heydrich started I think connection
was compromised hope not what's up
thermal
leave them in I got your back
walk down the halls copy
Charlie most of it the terminal position
at the terminal
[Music]
he's in the halls seal the exits be
positioned north exit here in position
south exit
I'm tracking here yep
around you give up
[Music]
one man left
hey we really appreciate you guys taking
the time to watch this video we put a
lot of work into it and so did a lot of
other people also we had a lot of crazy
camera tricks and setups to pull this
one off
see how I check it behind the scene
there's good stuff in there we show how
he did it
this is video we've been wanting to do
for a long time and if you want to see
what inspired it you should check out
the news play sell trailer for spies vs
mercs it's pretty sweet and I think we
did a good job recreating it thanks for
watching guys onwards to the next video
green-screen out